quando sono andato da chiabra Mi sono
innamorato di questo si chiama Action
Plastic Model kit fuori dalla scatola
questo
Che cazzo devo fare qua è passata una
settimana e io non ho pensato ad altro
oggi finalmente andremo a montare il
Metal Gear
venite con me ho ancora tutto dentro la
valigia Non sono soddisfatto niente Oggi
finalmente ho un posto dove andare Per
far sì che questo affare prenda vita
quindi il Metal Gear si farà andiamo
[Musica]
sarei aspettato tutto tranne che questo
Ma tu davvero sai fare questa cosa
come hai iniziato a farli mi interessa
questa cosa Sì ho visto Tik Tok
questo è facile Questo ci mettiamo
dentro
una foto alla mia nonna ha scritto
quando la festa della mamma l'hai
sentito sotto quel merda di figlio non
mi ha fatto niente
ragazzi siamo finalmente alla fine
donna
avete già la macchina pesa
Allora ragazzi ho lasciato il Metal Gear
a casa di Simone e mi ha detto nel
mentre che io faccio questo tu fatti
l'altro Metal Gear perché ovviamente ne
ho due ieri ho capito bene il
funzionamento del montaggio dei gumpra e
quindi oggi mi monto io il secondo Metal
Gear Metal Gear Rey Mannaggia
[Musica]
è facile quello che credi eh
raga ce l'ho fatta non c'è voluto molto
alla fine
ci ho messo un attimo Ma te l'ho detto
che è facile farli
[Musica]